james
le destin nous réunit à nouveau
à présent pour mon ennemi est mon ennemi
comment est ce arrivé
quand on vit assez longtemps
cette plus en plus dur de ses parts elle
bien du mal les méchants des héros de
nos jours
avant on pouvait se retrouver dans une
pièce avec nos ennemis aujourd'hui il
flotte au gré de l'éther
thème toujours tu ne le savais pas
qu'est ce que c'est ils te rends pas
compte
elle est des leurs je ne sait rien
d'elle dès que son secret à notre à la
surface
ça te tuera à coup sûr
nous éradiquons des gens tous les deux
pour créer
mais moi j'essaie d'être un peu plus
mettez que le
j'ai rencontré votre nouvelle double
zéro une jeune femme vraiment des armes
vous avez déjà piloté ce genre d'argent
monde où êtes vous encore
si on réussit pas
il n'aura plus rien à sauver
c'est quand vous voulez vous êtes en
retard
pourrais-je passer une agréable soirée
avant que le monde n'explose